ladies and gentlemen please welcome a
couple of old [ __ ] Dustin Hoffman and
Barbra Streisand
look beautiful Thank You Bernie
um it is our pleasure to announce the
nominations for Best Motion Picture each
film not only enhances the stature of
the many artists whose team effort
brought it to fruition but also as to
the luster of the entire film community
so proudly we present these five
outstanding films The Aviator Michael
Mann Graham King producer Finding
Neverland Richard and Gladstein and
Nellie Bellflower producers Million
Dollar Baby Clint Eastwood Alvarez ruddy
and Tom Rosenberg producers ray Taylor
Hackford Stuart Benjamin Howard Baldwin
producers sideways Michael London
producer and the Oscar goes to the Oscar
goes to oh go ahead well the problem is
I forgot my glasses but okay
I'm so happy to give you this again
Clint
destroyed
Million Dollar Baby was nominated for
seven Academy Awards tonight winning
four for Best Supporting Actor lead
actress directing and Best Picture
Albertus ruddy was one who gave us the
script and I came here in 1972 was it 72
to give him the Oscar for the Godfather
and so I'm glad to be back with him
tonight thank you
actually this is the third award
ceremony we've gotten to in this
category and tonight we won and I will
tell you every time I started going to
this thing I say I'm gonna join myself
whether I win or lose but believe me as
Arnold said it's better to then I love
it
thank you everybody now this this is a
great honor that celebrates the talent
of Hilary Swank Morgan Freeman and the
genius of clinics I'm very
No
what one other cook I want to thank
Angelica Houston who introduced me to FX
tool and Paul Haggis writing a brilliant
screenplay the only thing left for me to
do in my life now is thank my wife who
believed when I was worried my two great
children I'm going to sit down to get a
piece of lemon pie with the real filling
I'm gonna look at this and then I'm
gonna die and go to heaven
thank you I want to thank Warner
Brothers alan horne teen spirit denim
run from you and i especially want to
thank my partners gary Lucchese and
Terry McKay and everybody at Lakeshore
and of course the fantastic and fabulous
Clint Eastwood and my other partner
Elizabeth Alcon and their and everybody
at the mission ranch in moderate County
is watching the [ __ ]
you